Lisa wants to know what actor would you  want to play you in a movie about your  life Lisa when the movie of my life is  made which I'm pretty substantially  betting on it happening you know what  I'm looking for in 25 years because i'm  a slow grinder right like don't get  confused vaynernation 99% of the world  has no idea who I am minimally but I'm a  grinder and I feel good about where I  sit in the is this worthy of a movie  lexicon in 25 30 years from now so I  don't know who I want to play me because  obviously there'll be different versions  but whoever is the most attractive would  be the direction I'd be looking for oh  crap wait subscribe do I need  subscriptions because I can't push this  many right hooks in social so subscribe